[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend um
es gleich vorweg zu sagen wer erwartet
hatte dass ich Olaf Scholz bei seinem
Auftritt in der Wurst zum Thema
Kampfpanzer äußert und die eine oder
andere Richtung sah sich enttäuscht da
kam nichts jedenfalls nicht von sich aus
statt über Kampfpanzer sprach Scholz
lieber über Wiederaufbau der Ukraine und
ihren Weg in die EU was aber ja
voraussetzt dass das Land dann noch
existiert und nicht zu einer russischen
Kolonie unterworfen wurde aber so ganz
kann man mit dem Schweigen nicht durch
beobachteten Susanne Biedenkopf und
fräule
die deutsche Fahne übergroß auf der
Videowand das Forum wartet auf den
Bundeskanzler doch erst wollen die noch
einmal sprechen die besonders viel Angst
haben vor der russischen
aggressions
die Erwartungen an die zeitenwände
lassen Deutschland keine Zeit wir
brauchen sie jetzt wir brauchen jetzt
die Führung von Deutschland die Ukraine
braucht das Litauen braucht das wenn wir
Sicherheit in Europa wollen
Europe
Auftritt Olaf Scholz überall wurde
derzeit hingeht verfolgt in eine Frage
wird er sich für die Lieferung von
Kampfpanzern aussprechen Deutschland
steht in der Kritik Scholz findet zu
Unrecht und zählt auf was seine
Regierung alles schon leistet
ja die Fans systems like I
rstabwehrsysteme Artillerie und
Schützenpanzer markieren einen
entscheidenden Wendepunkt in der
deutschen außen und Sicherheitspolitik
das reicht dem Publikum aber nicht sie
wollen wissen ob Olaf Scholz die
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern weiter
blockiert
Herr Bundeskanzler danke für alles was
Sie für uns tun sagt ein ukrainischer
Journalist und dann kommt die
eigentliche Frage
die westlichen Verbündeten die USA und
andere sind bereit den nächsten Schritt
zu gehen nur die deutsche Zögerlichkeit
hat das bislang verhindert warum zögern
Sie warum warten sie
wollen verhindern dass dies ein Krieg
zwischen Russland und der NATO wird das
ist doch im Sinne der Ukraine so wie ich
das nach meinen Gesprächen mit ihnen
verstehen
Missverständnis denn unmittelbar nach
dem Auftritt des Bundeskanzlers kam der
andere Auftritt der von Präsident
selinski der schon mehrfach Kampfpanzer
gefordert hat
Entscheidungen müssen schneller fallen
ich rufe sie auf schneller zu
entscheiden die zivilisierte Welt muss
schneller reagieren denn die Tragödien
überschatten das Leben Tyrannei
überschattet Demokratie
ihre präsentiert die NATO Jens
Stoltenberg weiß um die Gefahr einer
Eskalation dennoch fordert er weitere
Waffen ohne das Wort Kampfpanzer in den
Mund zu nehmen wir brauchen mehr
Unterstützung mit schweren und modernen
Waffen dies ist ein Kampf für unsere
Werte für die Demokratie
auf der Bühne mit ihm die ukrainische
vize-regierungschefin sie spricht das
Wort aus Kampfpanzer wie kommen wir an
mehr Waffen
Raketenabwehrsysteme schweres Gerät
Kampfpanzer
Olaf Scholz bewegt sich nicht Druck hin
oder Druck her er hat sein eigenes Tempo
für Entscheidungen
und dann schalten wir noch zu Ulf Rolle
im Schneegestöber von Davos ulfi kam
dann bei dem Jahr doch sehr hochrangigen
Publikum in Davos der Auftritt des
deutschen Bundeskanzlers an
also ich glaube vor allem viele
europäische Regierungschefs waren doch
dann sehr enttäuscht sie hatten doch
gehofft dass der Bundeskanzler ein
Signal gibt oder ein Zeichen gibt wie
man ein Kompromiss findet bei dem Thema
panzerlieferung aber das hat er nicht
getan er blieb hart und so ist Olaf
Scholz bei diesem Thema doch sehr
isoliert und Europa rutscht eigentlich
bei einer sehr großen
sicherheitsrutschenfrage in eine Krise
da ist auf der einen Seite die große
Gruppe von Staats- und Regierungschefs
in Europa die sagen wir brauchen diese
Panzer Lieferung an die Ukraine damit
sich das Land gegen die Russen
verteidigen kann und auf der anderen
Seite ist der Kanzler der eben
Sicherheitsbedenken hat und deshalb sich
nicht bewegt ich glaube lange kann man
diese Spaltung Europas nicht aufrecht
erhalten und es muss eigentlich jetzt
dringend eine Lösung her weil vor allem
die Europäer weiter Druck machen werden
auf Olaf Scholz scheint ja auch
irgendwie Bewegung zu sein jetzt am
Abend kamen da interessante Meldungen
unter anderem berichtet die Süddeutsche
Zeitung Scholz sei zu
kampfpanzerlieferung und aber nur wenn
die Amerikaner mitmachen
ja das ist eine sehr sehr spannende
Meldung es kommen auch andere Zeitungen
die das Melden es soll ein Telefonat es
hat ein Telefonat gegeben zwischen dem
amerikanischen Präsidenten beiden und
Olaf Scholz am Dienstag und das solch
gescholz gesagt haben wir sind bereit
Kampfpanzer zu liefern wenn ihr das auch
tut die Amerikaner haben das offen
gehalten bisher aber all das was man da
liest das passt schon zu der denke von
Olaf Scholz zu seiner Dramaturgie und
Strategie er hat ja immer wieder gesagt
dass er keiner Alleingänge will und das
heißt für ihn er will dass die
Amerikaner mitmachen das hat er immer
wieder auch bei seinen Entscheidungen
Waffen liefern sich immer an den
Amerikanern und orientiert alles könnte
wahrscheinlich am Freitag dann doch sehr
deutlich werden wenn man den Rammstein
sich die Verteidigungsminister treffen
ob es dann zu einem Kompromiss kommt
also vielleicht gibt es da Bewegung
danke für die Einschätzung nach Davos
derweil die Ukraine heute schon wieder
eine Tragödie verkraften muss den
Absturz eines Hubschraubers nahe Kiew zu
den Insassen die dabei ums Leben kamen
gehörte der ukrainische Innenminister
sein Stellvertreter und leitende
Mitarbeiter und als sei das nicht schon
schlimm genug stürzte der Hubschrauber
auch noch ausgerechnet auf einen
Kindergarten insgesamt gab es 14 Tote
und viele Verletzte
Krüger ist unsere Reporte in der Ukraine
in Kiew Tim was weiß man inzwischen über
den Hergang dieser Tragödie
also dieser abgestürzte Hubschrauber war
ganz offenbar eine Maschine des
ukrainischen Rettungsdienstes auf dem
Weg zu einem Frontabschnitt er ist dann
kurz hinter der Kira Stadtgrenze in
einen Vorort gestürzt und dabei kam es
eben zu dieser entsetzlich hohen
Opferzahl und dieser Absturz war auch
ein Schlag für die ukrainische Regierung
denn sie hat im Grunde von jetzt auf
gleich die gesamte Führung des
Innenministeriums verloren also den
Innenminister selber seinen
Stellvertreter ein Staatssekretär und
noch weitere Mitarbeiter und der
ukrainische Präsident selenski hat
natürlich sofort kontrolliert hat den
Angehörigen sein Beileid ausgesprochen
und sprach von einer furchtbaren
Tragödie ja für ihn ein Schlag was wird
denn über die Ursachen gesagt
also bislang gibt es noch keine
gesicherten Erkenntnisse über die
Ursachen dieses Absturzes der
ukrainische Geheimdienst verfolgt ganz
offenbar drei Stränge zum einen könnte
es sich um ein Verstoß gegen die
flugvorschriften gehandelt haben oder
aber bei diesem Absturz habe es
technische Probleme gegen können oder
das ganze war womöglich wirklich
wirklich eine gezielte Zerstörung dieser
Maschine dieses Helikopters das ganze
wird jetzt untersucht das ist eine
Kommission eingesetzt worden allerdings
hat ein Sprecher der ukrainischen
Luftwaffe gesagt dass er nicht mit
schnellen Ergebnissen rechnet sondern
dass das Ganze mehr als ein zwei Tage
dauern könnte bis wirklich ein
belastbarer Bericht vorliegt also wir
müssen noch etwas warten bis wir
wirklich wissen warum dieser
Hubschrauber heute morgen in der Nähe
von KF abgestürzt ist danke Tim für
diese Informationen direkt aus Kiel
eine junge Ukrainerin formulierte es auf
Twitter heute so jeden Tag wache ich auf
lese die News und möchte sofort nur noch
schreiben warum passiert das meinem Land
meinen Leuten womit verdienen wir all
diesen Horror dieses Unglück
der größte Horror der letzten Wochen
waren nie pro so sah der Wohnblock in
der Millionenstadt vorher aus und so
nach dem Raketeneinschlag das Grauen kam
ohne Vorwarnung das risst Familien
Nachbarn Freunde aus dem Leben Kinder
Mütter Väter starben und unter den
Trümmern liegen noch vermisste für die
ist keine Hoffnung mehr gibt
die ganze Ukraine trauert um die Opfer
erinnert an ihren Namen und Gesichtern
Ulrike
in der kleinen gelben Küche steht noch
die Obstschale auf dem Tisch es ist ein
Bild das zum Symbol werden könnte für
die Grausamkeit dieses Krieges hier
lebte Familie corinowski bis ein
Raketeneinschlag am Samstag ihr Leben so
plötzlich und so brutal veränderte
dieses Video zeigt die Geburtstagsfeier
der kleinen Tochter ihr Vater wird bei
dem Raketenangriff getötet
michailo corinnawski war Boxtrainer
seine Frau und seine Töchter waren zum
Zeitpunkt des Angriffs spazieren
[Musik]
die Wucht des raketeneinschlags sind
nepro war gewaltig 45 Menschen sterben
darunter sechs Kinder mehr als 70
Menschen werden zum Teil schwer verletzt
[Musik]
werden sie geht mit meinem Sohn in
dieselbe Klasse ihre Eltern sind wohl
beide tot
wir könnten dort liegen alle Erwachsene
und Kinder
noch immer werden viele vermisst doch
die ukrainische Armee hat nun keine
Hoffnung mehr noch lebende zu finden
auch Irina und olja sterben die beiden
Freundinnen waren Zahnärztinnen beide
hatten sich als Freiwillige bei der
ukrainischen Armee gemeldet um Soldaten
zu versorgen ihr Leben ausgelöscht
[Musik]
olja war zu Beginn des Krieges nach
Polen gegangen doch sie bekam Heimweh
und kehrte zurück
den Toten ein Gesicht geben von
tausenden geteilt werden Ihre Fotos in
den sozialen Medien sie sollen nicht
vergessen werden
auch Maria wird getötet sie war erst 15
Jahre alt Schulsprecherin ihre
Leidenschaft der Tanz bekannte sagen sie
sei allein zu Hause gewesen
[Musik]
hier in kniepro tragen Sie nun michailo
zu Grabe den Boxtrainer
seine Frau ist gekommen mit ihren
Töchtern
und jetzt macht erstmal Heinz Wolf
weiter mit anderen Nachrichten
es gibt weiter Diskussionen über die
silvesterkrawalle in Berlin und anderen
Städten der Bundestag hat in einer
aktuellen Stunde darüber debattiert und
von der Berliner Polizei gibt es einen
Zwischenstand zu den Ermittlungen
demnach wurden dort bis gestern 44
mutmaßliche Angreifer auf Polizisten und
Feuerwehrleute identifiziert 18 sein
Ausländer 10 hätten eine ausländische
und die deutsche Nationalität 16 sein
deutsche in ganz Deutschland gab es in
der Silvesternacht laut einem Bericht
des Tagesspiegels mindestens 282
Angriffe auf Einsatzkräfte der Polizei
und der Feuerwehr
vom bundesarbeitsgerecht kommt ein
Urteil zum Thema gleicher Lohn für
gleiche Arbeit im konkreten Fall bekam
ein Rettungsassistent Recht der als
geringfügig Beschäftigter von seinem
Arbeitgeber den gleichen Stundenlohn
fordert wie in die Vollzeitbeschäftigten
erhalten der Richter sahen in der
unterschiedlichen Regelung bei der
Diensteinteilung keinen ausreichenden
Grund für eine unterschiedliche
Bezahlung bei gleicher Qualifikation und
identischer Tätigkeit
nach einem Brand in einem Reutlinger
Pflegeheim für psychisch Kranke
ermitteln die Behörden wegen des
Verdachts des dreifachen Mordes und
elfachen Mordversuchs im Fokus steht
eine 57 Jahre alte Bewohnerin die das
vorher nach ersten Erkenntnissen in
ihrem Zimmer selbst gelegt haben könnte
und dabei schwer verletzt wurde ein
mögliches Tatmotiv der psychisch kranken
Frau werde noch ermittelt im
Obergeschoss der Einrichtung waren bei
einem Brand bei dem Brand in einer
Wohngruppe am Dienstagabend drei
Bewohner ums Leben gekommen
die EU plant weitere Sanktionen gegen
Iran wie dem ZDF aus Diplomatenkreisen
bestätigt wurde sollen 37 Personen und
Organisationen auf die Sanktionsliste
gesetzt werden die Personen die an der
brutalen Unterdrückung von Protesten
beteiligt waren die Strafmaßnahmen
Einreiseverbote und Einfrieren von
Vermögenswerten sollen am Montag bei
einem Außenministertreffen formell auf
den Weg gebracht werden
in Japan hat das Oberste Gericht den
Freispruch Dreier ehemaliger tep-manager
bestätigt im Zusammenhang mit der
Atomkatastrophe in Fukushima 2011 hätten
die drei Angeklagten nicht fahrlässig
gehandelt ihnen war vorgeworfen worden
keine vorbeugenden Schutzmaßnahmen
ergriffen zu haben zur Begründung des
Freispruchs hieß es ein derartiger
Tsunami sei nicht vorhersehbar gewesen
jedes Jahr brechen an die 50.000
Schülerinnen und Schüler hierzulande die
Schule ab und haben dann nicht mal einen
Hauptschulabschluss dazu passt das unter
den 20 bis 34-Jährigen rund 15 Prozent
keine Berufsausbildung haben für eine
alternde Gesellschaft die unter
Fachkräftemangel leidet müsste das ein
Weckruf sein mehr in Bildung investieren
Lehrermangel bekämpfen laut dem heute
veröffentlichten deutschen
schulbarometer einer Umfrage unter
Schulleitungen ist der massive
Personalmangel das mit Abstand größte
Problem
da würde es natürlich helfen zumindest
auf längere Sicht wenn mehr junge Leute
Lust hätten auf Lehramt zu studieren und
den Beruf dann auch tatsächlich
auszuüben Einblick in die Universitäten
kann da allerdings eher ernüchtern
stellt Stefanie gergosch fest
Universitäten sollten Lust auf Bildung
machen Katharina Schorn erlebt anderes
in Berlin studiert sie auf Lehramt
möchte an die Grundschule doch hier
waren sie davor in der zweiten oder
dritten Vorlesung in meinem ersten
Semester wurde uns das schon gesagt dass
ja der Beruf des Lehrer also Lehrkräfte
eins der höchsten Risiko
Wahrscheinlichkeiten für Burnout haben
und das hat mich schon geschockt immer
mehr Schüler in den Klassen Georgios
sollbach studiert trotzdem Chemie und
Politik auf lärmt ein Problem des
Studiums sagt er die Praxisanteile kämen
viel zu spät etwa jeder fünfte bricht
sein Lehramtsstudium dann ab
die Gründe sind glaube ich einmal die
Unattraktivität des Lärms Berufs später
die mentale Überforderung mit zu vollen
Schulklassen und die Lehramtsausbildung
hat gewisse Mängel vor allem in der in
den praxisnahen Kompetenzen Katharina
und Georgios wollen dabei bleiben
Katharina unterrichtet sogar schon auch
wenn sie noch nicht fertig ist 10.000
der Lehrkräfte fehlen an deutschen
Schulen bereits gleichzeitig steigen die
Schülerzahlen größere Klassen
Mehrbelastung des Lehrpersonals
stundenausfälle das besorgt auch Sie
weiß ich nicht wo es das in den nächsten
Jahren hingeht wenn jetzt die sich sich
der Lehrermangel oder Lehrkräftemangel
immer weiter verstärkt dann wird es ja
nicht einfacher sondern wird es ja
eigentlich nur noch schlimmer irgendwie
und das macht mir schon ein bisschen
Angst dazu findet nicht jeder der auf
Lehramt studieren will einen Platz viele
Universitäten haben eine hohe
Zulassungsbeschränkung den Numerus
Clausus kurz NC
also das ist absurd also wir brauchen
dringend Lehrkräfte und wir haben in sie
immer noch an vielen Universitäten bei
der Aufnahme einen harten erzählt
teilweise 1 und noch etwas das ist eine
Folge des Abbaus von Studienplätzen sind
einfach zu wenig da wo man gedacht hat
wegen
Geburtenrückgang dauert ewig aber
tausende von Studienplätzen in
Deutschland abgebaut wer einen Platz
ergat hat stößt oft auf Mangel so wenig
Seminarplätze zu wenig Professoren Kevin
Gumprecht studiert Englisch und Sport an
der Humboldt-Universität gerade in Sport
habe ich ein großes Defizit eigentlich
wird erwartet dass wir drei bis vier
Praxiskursen Semester absolvieren dann
kommt es dazu dass am Ende 700 Leute
sich auf 70 Plätze im schwimmseminar
bewerben und da hat man einfach keine
Chance dass es viele Leute spielen auch
deshalb geht er auf die Straße Schule
muss anders das Motto im Moment studiert
ihre Generation mitten in eine
bildungsmiserie hinein
es war ein schwieriges treffen heute
Abend in
Illerkirchberg in Oberschwaben nur
Bürgerinnen und Bürger der Stadt waren
eingeladen und wollte verhindern dass
die Veranstaltung von auswärtigen
Gruppen politisch instrumentalisiert
wird denn das werden die Ereignisse von
Illerkirchberg eh schon seit langem 2019
wurde ein Mädchen dort von vier
Asylbewerbern vergewaltigt und im
letzten Jahr im Dezember Griff einen
Asylsuchende aus Eritrea aus heiterem
Himmel und auf offener Straße zwei
Schulmädchen an er attackierte sie mit
einem Messer eine der beiden eine
14-Jährige starb ihre 13-jährige
Freundin wurde schwer verletzt Eva
Schiller Berichte
das Vertrauen ist verloren gegangen in
Illerkirchberg seit dem Mord ein ECE
Gerüchte über geflüchtete brodeln da ist
Angst Wut
aus Sorge vor rechtsradikalen dürfen nur
Einwohner in die Veranstaltung der
Behörden nicht das erste Mal halte es
uns entgegen 2019 hat im Ort deine
Gruppe geflüchtete ein Mädchen
vergewaltigt ein Täter wurde nach der
Haft wieder hier untergebracht das macht
was mit den Leuten ist doch klar und ich
verstehe nach wie vor nicht wenn ich
sage mal wenn ich jetzt in Syrien oder
wo immer sowas machen würde was die mit
der machen würden es ist aber tiefe
irgendwo Enttäuschung man hat sich von
kleinen obwohl gefühlt im Dorf so
geworden und das sowas passieren kann am
Tatort dort wo der Flüchtling aus
Eritrea ätsche und ihre Freundin wohl
völlig willkürlich niedergestochen hat
treffen wir mashallah dummlu ethes
Eltern erzählt der Kreisrat hatten die
Größe in einem Brief vor Hass und Hetze
zu warnen ihnen schulde man Aufarbeitung
wie kann es sein dass Menschen die zu
geflüchtet sind die wir ja aufnehmen und
unsere
Gastfreundschaftlichkeit zeigen dass man
auch wissen wie sie ticken es würde ja
schon sehr gut tun wenn man
professionelle Unterstützung hätte in
Form von Sozialarbeitern da ist die eine
Frage die in Illerkirchberg wieder laut
wird werden geflüchtete eher straffällig
die Zahl Tatverdächtiger Zuwanderer
sinkt aber mit 7,1% sind sie trotzdem
überproportional vertreten bei
Verbrechen gegen das Leben sechsmal so
auffällig wie deutsche Täter
hauptsächlich junge Männer für
Baden-Württembergs Justizministerium
liegt die Lösung auf der Hand abschieben
dafür gibt es extra einen sonderstab mit
dem markigen Titel gefährliche Ausländer
wir bearbeiten gerade so eine
dreistellige Anzahl von Menschen und das
Ziel ist klar möglichst diese Menschen
wieder aus der Landes zu bringen
statt nur auf Abschiebung zu bauen die
oft nicht funktioniert fordert Katalin
Dormann Konzepte an der Uni Konstanz hat
ihr Team ein psychologisches
Screening-Verfahren einen Fragebogen
entwickelt das Ergebnis 50% der jungen
männlichen Flüchtlinge psychisch
belastet 20% gewaltbereit
wir würden uns wünschen dass das
Screening deutschlandweit und
flächendeckend angewendet wird und zwar
direkt nach der Einreise der
geflüchteten ich plädiere sehr dafür
dass wir das auch umsetzen und nicht
erst wenn etwas Schlimmes passiert ist
und alle wieder überrascht sind in
Illerkirchberg gab es wohl Warenzeichen
aber selbst wenn die Behörden sie ernst
genommen hätten da sind weder genug
Sozialarbeiter noch Therapieplätze um zu
reagieren
seit Anfang Dezember sitzen die
ehemalige Vizepräsidentin des
EU-Parlaments evakali und weitere
Verdächtige im Gefängnis einer von ihnen
will auspacken und seine Strafe zu
melden das könnte für die anderen noch
sehr unangenehm werden auch für weitere
EU-Abgeordnete die damals in den Fokus
der Ermittler Rücken
das Muster ist immer wieder das gleiche
man lässt sich einladen man nimmt Geld
an teils den Papiertüten so profan muss
man sich das wohl vorstellen der
Imageschaden für die EU übersteigt die
Summen um die ist dabei ging bei weitem
Florian Neuhann Bericht
die flurgespräche im Straßburger
EU-Parlament sie kennen heute meist nur
ein Thema was kommt da wohl noch wenn er
wirklich auspackt er Pierre Antonio
panzeri ex-abgeordneter Schlüsselfigur
in der Korruptionsaffäre panzeri hat wie
es bisher in der belgischen
Justizgeschichte nur einmal vorkam einen
förmlichen Vertrag mit der
Staatsanwaltschaft unterschrieben
Strafmilderung gegen das was ein Anwalt
im belgischen Fernsehen so beschreibt
er wird alles sagen müssen was er weiß
begünstigten der Korruption die
Organisationsweise den genauen Fluss des
Geldes
ist gegen diese Ankündigung verblasst
heute auch ein erster Neuanfang der
Luxemburger Sozialdemokrat mag Angel
wird zum Vizepräsidenten gewählt zum
Nachfolger der wegen Korruptionsverdacht
Inhaftierten evakaii das Parlament steht
vor dem Scherben einer Affäre
meine Fresse wenn das bei der nächsten
Europawahl nicht im Desaster enden soll
dann kann es jetzt nur einen Maßstab
geben für uns hier volle Transparenz es
ist Roberta Mezzola die
Parlamentspräsidentin heute ein Jahr im
Amt die sich auch im ZDF-Interview an
die Spitze dieser Bewegung setzt kann
ich versprechen dass so etwas nie wieder
passieren wird nein aber ich werde mein
bestes geben damit alle Schlupflöcher
geschlossen werden
ein Schlupfloch das wären etwa
gesponserte Reisen dem ZDF liegt eine
Liste aller Reisen vor die sich
Parlamentarier in dieser Legislatur von
Dritten bezahlen ließen angemeldet
rechtlich zulässig politisch aber oft
fragwürdig so reiste der afd-abgeordnete
Gunnar Beck im Oktober 21 nach Moskau
zur weibeobachtung finanziert von
Russland und der konservative
tschechische Abgeordnete der hoffowski
ließ sich für drei Tage auf die
Malediven einladen in dieses Luxus
Ressort er selbst kann war kein Problem
entdecken Ivos ich war und bin
Vorsitzender der Malediven
freundschaftsgruppe im Europäischen
Parlament wir müssen doch miteinander
reden ich habe dort das maledivische
Parlament besucht auf dem Markt ist
Parlament wer sich einladen lässt kann
kaum objektiv sein das führt dazu dass
Abgeordnete in der Schuld ihres
Gastgebers stehen und das mit
politischen Gefälligkeiten zurückzahlen
es sind nur ein paar Abgeordnete die
hier bislang unter echtem
Korruptionsverdacht stehen wofür sie
genau bezahlt wurden ist weiter offen
fest steht nur wem sie geschadet haben
der gesamten Europäischen Union
[Applaus]
und jetzt der Blick auf die Wirtschaft
Heinz an der Börse ging es für den DAX
nach dem deutlichen Plus seit
Jahresbeginn heute gebremst weiter und
der schloss mit einem ganz leichten
Minus auf ein Unternehmen wollen wir mit
Valerie Haller genauer schauen auf BASF
der Chemie Riese meldete überraschend
einen Milliardenverlust woran liegt ja
das geht größtenteils auf das Konto der
Tochter Wintershall die mehrheitlich
BASF gehört der Öl- und gasproduzent hat
eng mit Gazprom in Russland
zusammengearbeitet und wird sich jetzt
aus dem Land zurückziehen ein teurer
Schlussstrich BASF muss auf Winterzeit
über 7 Milliarden Euro abschreiben
jahrelang haben wintersaldea und BASF
hier in Sibirien aus billigen russischen
Gas prächtigen Profit geschlagen und
auch nach Ausbruch des Krieges daran
festgehalten doch das Verhältnis zu
Russland hat sich verschlechtert die
Zentrale in Kassel gibt bekannt das
Unternehmen beabsichtigt sich
vollständig aus Russland zurückzuziehen
die point Ventures also die russischen
Beteiligungen wurden de facto
wirtschaftlich enteignet Winters Hall
förderten Sibirien auch Gaskondensat
Recherchen des ZDF mit dem Spiegel haben
ergeben dass Winters heilkondensat an
Gazprom lieferte der russische
Staatskonzern nutzte dieses zur
kerosinherstellung und belieferte die
russische Luftwaffe die Entscheidung ist
richtig und überfällig denn wintersaal
ist seit 2014 an der Finanzierung der
russischen Kriegskasse beteiligt
insbesondere an der Produktion von
Kerosin für russische Kriegsflugzeuge
und russische Kriegswaffen Winters Hall
und BASF stehen wie kaum ein anderes
Unternehmen für die Verflechtung
deutscher Energiewirtschaft mit Russland
nun ziehen Sie die Reißleine viel zu
spät wie viele sagen
Valeria vielen Dank
bei den Australian Open hat nach
Alexander Zverev auch Laura Siegemund
den Einzug in die zweite Runde geschafft
Siegemund gewann ihr Auftaktspiel gegen
die Italienerin Lucia bronzetti in drei
Sätzen und sie trifft nun auf Irina
Camelia bigu aus Rumänien und jetzt die
Zahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch sie lauten
wie immer ohne Gewähr 1 8 21 25 37 46
die Superzahl 9 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 557
das war es im heute journal im
auslandsjournal geht es gleich weiter
unter anderem mit einer Reportage aus
Österreichs Skigebieten die jetzt quasi
jede Schneeflocke feiern und um 0 Uhr
gibt es dann unser heute schon mal
Update mit Christopher Wehrmann mit
einem Interview mit dem
Europaabgeordneten Rainer bütighofer zur
Forderung nach Leopard Panzern für die
Ukraine auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend es sind viele Thies die der
derzeit um Mitteleuropa Kreisen und
dreh- und Angelpunkt ist ein vielleicht
etwas unscheinbar wirkendes tief dieses
kleine tief das morgen über Dänemark
weiter bis zur Ostsee zieht dieses
kleine tief ist aber sehr sehr stark und
das zeichnet sich besonders auch beim
Wind ab sie sehen hier sehr schön diesen
wolkenwirbel dieses Tief bringt schon
heute Nacht Schnee und Schnee Regenfälle
die weiter ostwärts ziehen in einzelnen
Schneeschauern können da durchaus mal 5
cm Schneefall morgen über Tag sind diese
Schneefälle weiter in Richtung Osten
auch in den Mittelgebirgen kann es dann
mal etwas länger schneiden machen Sie
sich also heute Nacht auf gefährlich
glatte Straßen gefasst besonders in
Nordwesten mit diesem neuen tief und
Schnee und Schnee Regen etwas Schnee
fällt auch noch in der Lausitz unter dem
alten Rand die Temperaturen dazu sinken
auf plus ein bis minus 9 Grad und dann
kältesten wird es z.B im Thüringer Wald
im Schwarzwald oder auch auf der
Schwäbischen und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen in den Mittelgebirgen
und am Alpenrand im leichten Dauerfrost
sonst werden zarte Plusgrade erreicht im
Nordwesten sind es vier bis sechs Grad
und morgen über Tag geht es weitere
Schnee und Schnee Regenschauer an der
Nordsee vielleicht auch mal ein Gewitter
an der Ostseeküste gibt es einen starken
stürmischen Südwestwind etwas
Freundliches ist ganz im Osten und ganz
im Süden und winterlich geht es in den
nächsten Tagen auch weiter dann kommt
der Schnee mehr und mehr aus Osten ich
wünsche dir noch einen schönen Abend